all right so before we get into this
video I just wanted to kind of throw out
a little giveaway that's going on so a
sponsor of mine that I often shout out
in videos and do also as well and this
one is called GE tracker they will be in
the description down below but they have
informed me that they are giving away
one free membership this month so if you
guys wanna be entered into that go ahead
and post your GE tracker name in the
comments down below and I will pick a
random winner other than that let's get
right on into the video come on pretty
girl hello everyone how are guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and today we are here with another money
making method so this can but this can
vary widely personally I'm just gonna
put this at how I make a mil a day doing
pretty much nothing and you guys may be
like well that sounds too good to be
true and I'm gonna tell you that that's
it's not it's literally it happens and
it's not it's not luck it's something
that will go down after this video just
this one specific and method I'm doing
but you can vary this widely and I'd
look to show you guys that here in a
second so this is how it made money on
my medium level account am I gonna get
into specifics on how much I've made
because it'd be spoiling the series but
it does make me a decent amount of money
and yeah we're gonna get right on into
itself going to go to the bank and grab
what we will be doing and that will be
putting together malediction Ward's so
as you guys can see here I have 15
pieces of a malediction mortar yes five
malediction boards and basically all you
have to do is just put them together and
you make money no sir I know sounds a
little too easy
after this video keep in mind this will
not be as profitable it may not even be
the most it may not even be profitable
so I recommend you look up the margins
beforehand however I'm gonna go over to
a sponsor of mine and their website GE
tracker they have a cool little feature
I'm gonna show you guys how we can apply
this and other methods than just this
one alright so we are going over to GE
tracker right now this is a website of
mine that I used also sponsor as I said
but if you have if you have the premium
service you can use one of these tools
you do not need the premium service for
this thing to work you can you can find
these on your own it just makes it a bit
more convenient so we go over to item
sets and crafting you guys are going to
be able to see a bunch of different ways
that you can combine things in-game and
potentially sell them off for more so as
you guys see here mental addiction
Ward's just by buying the shards and
then putting two them together to make a
ward itself is 300k profit odium is 2
70k prophet and from there you have a
ton of different things of just putting
together sets of different armors so I
mean realistically I ticked anything
above a hundred 150k because once you're
down here this can get a little varied
and there's not a demand for the paid
set then you might end up not making
that much money it may not be worth your
time for this example the video we will
be doing validation Ward's so what
you're gonna want to do if you don't
have this website and I just want to
look up stuff all you have to do is just
type in these pages calculate how much
it would take to buy all four pages then
from there you can go and find the page
set price once you find the page set
price just subtract the price for the
four four pages so what I do personally
if you are just doing like malediction
wards like I do I go over and just type
in part of malediction you're not gonna
find anything else in the game then from
there just take the approximate offer
price for all of these this is what
you're gonna want to put in your offer
for so as you guys can see here and
totally you should be spending about
three point four mil on the entirety of
these shards that you're gonna need and
then from there you can sell them on for
three point seven and make about 300k so
that's what I'm gonna be doing for this
video I'm gonna get in and show you guys
how I go about doing this all right so
came back over to uh old school and
before we get into this I'm just gonna
say something real quick what I'm going
to want to tell you guys is malediction
shards and odium shards will go through
the roof
I'd imagine after this video depending
on how big it gets so what you're gonna
want to do is maybe check those first
and if they aren't the best then go with
other page sets and other armor sets
that's gonna be the best way of going
about this this is why I've offered an
alternative in this video since I know
that maybe putting together these shards
may not be the best thing for you so
let's go ahead and I'm gonna show you
guys how I go about putting these into
shards can't just run out with all 15 of
them you'll probably die nope you
probably won't die but if you do you're
gonna lose a hell of a lot of money
alright so I'm gonna go through what
you're kind of gonna want to need so
personally what I bring is I bring some
like anti PK or deer just your typical
like like bhai just so that majors can't
get me really wouldn't risk too much in
this you don't wanna lose money off of
your gear you could go out there with
nothing on and pretend like you're not
doing anything out there but that leaves
you a little unprotected so that's up to
you depending on what you
do if you're going out with just gear
and showing people that you actually are
doing something out here I'd recommend
just taking a weapon so you can attack
back during fights on top of that
personally I take just a ton of Sarah
brews and sharks that's probably the
best way to go about this because you
typically won't eat them but when you do
you're gonna need them from their
stamina potions really good a prayer
potion just in case and typically I
bring two sets of shards you can bring
more or less depending on how much
you're willing to risk so with the
malediction shards after putting on
protect item I'll be able to keep all of
these which is though I'll be able to
keep all of these which is six points oh
six mil and I'll end up losing this
which is 109 K which is why I'm not too
worried about losing that it's
definitely more worth it to make -
rather than make one but it's personal
preference typically if I have more that
I need to do after this I'll take the
rest out there if I see that the coast
is clear so for the next inventory I'll
be running three but for now I'm going
to show you guys how to get there and
basically what to do so you're gonna
want to go to Edgeville with your glory
and go ahead and pull the lever to the
south so once you're up here get ready
to log out because there could be
someone standing next to this lever once
you find that it's clear you're gonna go
ahead run north and slash the web if
you're coming out here without a weapon
probably should have mentioned this
earlier bring a knife I'll put it on
screen earlier so that people can
remember this so once you slash the web
it's pretty self-explanatory it's not
too hard so you're gonna want to just
run from over here all the way into this
little pit right here so it's not too
bad I'll kind of speed it up and show
you guys how I go about running there
but if you guys know how to get there
then yeah just go ahead and do it
you
[__] what does this think once you've
made it on the app okay so once you've
made it on the outskirts of this volcano
you're gonna want to run to the very
center you'll see a little smithing icon
just go ahead and Forge these over the
molten lava so yeah it's not too bad and
also oh wait is it technically magma
since it's still in there
yeah I think so so what you're gonna
want to do we'll just make them once you
make them you're pretty protected
because if you die you're not gonna lose
anything as they are one item now so
you're good to go
from here you have two methods of which
you can get away you can go ahead and go
here to the obelisk which I will be
doing and teleporting around until
you're below level 30 wilderness and can
teleport with the glory or you can just
run straight south through this gate
right over here and just run until you
hit level 30 personally I think the
obelisk is is a little quicker however
it's a little less safe as you could get
teleported somewhere where there are PK
or so your preference decide what you
want to do all right
then once you have reached the level 30
just teleport back to wherever you need
to go
I'm personally teleporting back to
Edgeville and doing another trip but if
you're not doing another trip feel free
to just run to the GE and go ahead and
sell off everything you have so I'm
gonna go ahead and do these three and
then I'll be back here in a second
hopefully I don't die alright so once
you were done just go ahead and sell off
your malediction Ward's personally since
I have a lot I don't like to just dump
them in the grant exchange because you
know they could drop drastically on me
but if you only have one or two you
could probably answer sell it and be
more worth your time alright but that'll
be it for me today I hope this video was
helpful if it was make sure to leave all
you like also if you guys want to see
more in the future as soon as it goes
live make sure to subscribe down below
you can always hit me up in game if you
want to large exp lamp or in the clan
chat oh seven helpers one that I chill
in a lot of the time Twitter's in the
description down below but yeah other
than that hope you guys I don't